[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just realized I didn't ask who wanted
to intro this but it's okay cuz we're
already live and people can see us hi
everyone how's it going I'm Ben and this
is Persia and we're here to play Mortal
Kombat 11 with you guys it's all it's
all good yeah so if you would like to
play with us I'm going to hit that
button cuz that's not the one we wanted
to hit you can join the room called
GameSpot we've already got people
showing up so we're playing on
PlayStation 4 and you're gonna be
playing probably the whole time
oh boy probably the whole time well the
name of the lobby they got too scared
they saw you're 12 and 2 and they ran
away it's all fluke it's not real I
can't believe it but anyways hi guys
community Friday's live we're playing
some Oh MK oh he's back ok dragon tails
dragon - okay I didn't realize yeah
dragon tails is a gamer - it's real good
they're ready to get smoked bring it
Billy
ready you know I've been playing a lot
of fighting games why'd they go to
window fights this week and got bodied
so my confidence may not be very high
right but it's okay because I got my
cheap variation back the variation in
which I could not use back off of those
tournament standards
hey crime what's up welcome back hi Otto
thank you for returning in from Turkey
heck yeah French from France well
welcome and thank you oh those people
showing up I'm ready to ready to do the
thing and I hope you're all ready to
throw down in Mortal Kombat this will
probably be a much better showing than
when I did the fighting last week I want
to build it up too much
Oh No Persian MVC commentator what she's
doing a GameSpot hanging out dude doing
the the fighting games right now on on a
community Fridays see I get like a weird
complex every time I see noob saibot cuz
they're just I be there it is seeing
seeing noob tear through all the towers
all the time has just wrecked me is this
ps4 xbox we're on ps4 the room name is
GameSpot in all lowercase letters you
can join up challenge us if you see us
we'll try to get as many people as we
can and uh have some good fights I
thought maybe she worked there she does
work here Scarlet's really cool and I
probably should then how do you joining
us so if you want to join in what you've
got to do is you've got to search for a
room on PlayStation 4 called GameSpot
and all lowercase letters just come on
in come on and do the fight on the first
fight perfect
I am Skylar oh wow it's it all hurts so
much and then there's just a little bit
to top it all off oh yeah he doesn't
have like actual pupils or anything I
like that they match the eyes so weird
that it's just the front of his eye
that's white and the rest of it is like
a regular cosmetic yeah I guess so we
the truth are we doing two out of three
I don't think any I don't know if anyone
else didn't a lot B if it will do to it
I'd say for the first one at least a two
out of three and then we'll see how many
people are in there and if we've got a
few people will we'll keep it to like
one match just I'm gonna keep rotating
cuz that was just the first one of the
day that was the warm-up match this is
where it all actually counts normally
with info for the stream we had one but
the the graphics for being like or they
just weren't here I we usually do but
from now on I'm just gonna have to like
mouths word it every couple of minutes I
guess John says they're loving the
game's story it's short but so sweet
yeah it's got a lot of really good
fanservice ii stuff in it
Kung Lao Liu Kang best boys katana best
girl any moment
Johnny Cage is on the screen I love it
was real close though I like where Shawn
combos AI is ridiculous entirely I was
like in the point 0.3 0.4 percent for
towers last week and I didn't play a
single one was all AI supplements says
stories cool but now I hate before yeah
this is a good job turn turning her into
more of a more of a bad guy so just
joined heck yeah yeah again if you want
to join us and throw down just search
for the room game spot on and join
opinions
see now your your one in one though yeah
now you gotta actually you've got to
finally settle yeah yeah
my favorite Mortal Kombat game was
deception deception was pretty fun we
played through
the the Mortal Kombat games before 11:00
came out and like just to kind of I
think we're coming 11 might be my
favorite playing Mortal Kombat I sound
every time nine still is very high up
there well platform misses on ps4 crime
says who shooting on Monday cuz in game
spoiler discussion ban lifts that's it
according to the Turkish yeah the
directors themselves were like yeah the
ban is lifted on the sixth which is a
pretty strong statement if you ask me it
really it's very soon to worry most is
that noobs back know the characters seem
remotely surprised yeah it's it's a it's
a thing I also still can't get over the
fact that noob sounds like dr. claw and
I'll always bring it up anytime I talk
about new because it's just such a crazy
thing to me ultimate will stay forever
my fav Ultimates very good I only like
trilogy over ultimate because it has
Johnny Cage in it I think if I remember
right knee fatality is you got a friend
in me I did not know that they've got to
bring back the wishbone fatality for new
I'm waiting for that to happen cuz that
wishbone fatalities like top fatalities
oh I forgot the present blog but it the
Gregg grabs are very good I knew it was
gonna do teleporting grabs are also very
good those a good set though all the
Mersey happen its back on
oh I should've my arm right there it's
gonna say the as soon as you get a mercy
and someone's got a fatal blow it's yeah
it's kind of would give me at that point
but still was a good mercy see now I'm
like all the Twitter videos everyone
online they're like mercy and then
immediate super and it's like oh the
aaron black ones are my favorite because
they just goes full screen bring back
Kenshin Ermac I hope they do this is on
PlayStation 4 game spot all lowercase
yeah just search up that room join on in
yeah man I keep dropping that 1 to 4
combos so sad oh my good damage yeah
it's all good you get back you're trying
to get back from from playing the power
juice which is also mad funny games play
at Power Rangers game new day look at
this room I just accept whoever
challenges you first because they're
sitting there camping you the whole time
yeah right alright let's do this
thank you for joining us Jonah wants to
know what we think of the Joker being
leaked for the roster this this DC's the
Joker yeah it's uh there's some weird
data mining thing going on
there's glasses some references to the
Joker not Joker from persona or smash
brothers thank so many Joker's now write
or I don't know I wonder I guess it
would make sense cuz he's an injustice
hmm you know his character design was
pretty cool and then justice they
actually reference injustice in this
game too and some of the pre-fight
dialogue but Raiden and sub-zero only
think that it was a like a dream they
don't realize that they both had it
though that spin move for scorpions real
cool we've got some fertilized popping
up in betar which is no we do that
yeah like Batman Joker apparently is
supposed to show up the one on the weak
list that I'm kind of real stoked about
is ash Williams from Evil Dead because
Jonathan I have been like why is he not
in a mortal kombat game it would make so
much sense
I wish negan wasn't in Tekken 2 awesome
I respect your opinion but that spot
should've went to cosmic Uryu or ma Jima
Goro
anyway here's my entire PowerPoint
presentation on why they should put my
sweet yuccas boy in that game I need to
pick a teleport character huh yeah again
we can switch over to the camera really
quick and then we can turn off the
notifications for the sake of it's nice
that you guys are doing it yes
wanna make sure everything's you know
there it is just get the pop-up that one
we're good
boom sorry guys we'll look at those
later that and then we could play
somewhere I'm sorry we missed that cool
fatality though that's one of my
favorite oh wait now have the pics in
there to record the matches uh we do and
it is hooked up I can I can try to do it
if you'd like me to this thing is very
hot 80 and 86 you play a lot of games
people are definitely grinding it out
[Music]
oops
oh look I don't know how to work this as
a fun thing I don't know how Nikken
became a thing but I personally it was
excited for it when I was a eva and they
announced it it was like the most
shocking thing it was a real cool like
reveal oh I'll definitely give it that
cuz I didn't expect it it was is
completely out of nowhere and I I think
the problem with it is I'm just not a
big Walking Dead fan that's what kind of
left me out here yeah Jenna look I don't
know how to work this tell me where the
record button is and I'll hit it how do
you do a mercy so you tap a l2 or left
trigger and down three times in a row
really quick as you do king of the hill
cuz this is the way we can get more
people in team beanie we literally call
it out this morning to like four of us
in the the morning meeting that just had
beanies on
No Kino is really fun to play he's very
different from what i remember playing
though cuz i kind of like the i like you
guys like mp11 i like it i want to speak
for anyone else but I'm having a good
time with it
I'm so bad at the wakeup attacks it's
the button on the thing I'll poke around
for buttons wait I see I see I see a
record option John look I did it I
didn't realize that the little things at
the bottom were buttons
so it's it's recording now we've got it
oh you got Cassie in my trying to figure
out technology there's two wins that
happen to hear one on screen and one off
screen right we won against technology
and then we want to get stansky
let's do this got that eyeball thing
every time yeah does everyone have the
same color eyes no we saw noobs I was
actually noobs got like the absence of a
oh no if he counts get it I didn't
realize the do these look like buttons
like just the first glance just glance a
like decoration they're so symmetrical
exactly it's very nice it's an even
number but yeah we got a good reaction
on that uppercut ooh thank you thank you
I appreciate the acknowledgement on my
anti-air as like um you know a fighting
game player every time you miss an
anti-air you're like oh man that that
instant lock on here
I'm about to get shot y'all oh man this
game gear makes you want to dedicate
more time to playing as well as getting
augments and different combo
possibilities yeah I wish that the the
progression was still a little bit
better I do like that they updated it
and they've changed it and kind of
balance a lot of it out but I feel like
if I were to play Johnny Cage a whole
bunch I kind of only want Johnny Cage
things whole man can take it for a ride
right now the distance empty end in the
reload level are you guys I'm like 52
but that's all off line playing I'm
still kind of afraid to play get that
sonic Fox Tech in there ain't drop the
bird on you it's disrespectful Jonas
says they miss Aaron Black's old fatal
blow x-ray move yeah it was really cool
cuz it had like the bullet with
everyone's name on it your character got
the mix I missing again blocks yeah it's
hard her like a 50/50 50/50 off the sell
- don't really exist oh my good the
fatality isn't a heck of a thing yeah
and the eyeballs again
oh yeah that was rough black is really
good it's very good air in black game
playing hey every time I see a good air
and it makes me want to breath I'm like
dang I should be playing this character
because you get so much damage off the
acid set up really good especially in
his throws take a lot of like time it's
the animation and you're just taking
that damaged a whole time yeah was it
the cattle toss one that you can
actually give him like he just sits
there and just shoots you and you can
meter burn it and make a noise like it's
real good no except or 100 there there
are a whole bunch of pen oh yeah I think
that okay you've been challenged in
challenged by Wi-Fi you know when I'm
gonna accept it cuz it's all you one
game there you go but we shall
acknowledge here on Wi-Fi I'll fail to
connect never mind the game acknowledged
it there you go
know what's happening except maybe it's
I'm being overloaded with invites and
it's like the game just perfect there we
go alright why do they all have the same
scream in the fatality screen you know a
lot of people you know when you slow
everyone down they they sound similar
it's the only rationalization I can
think of bring it back though we'll be
fine good this is on twitch - nope just
you
like injustice suit I never really
played injustice to you but I don't
think you have to use it oh I never play
against character before totally oh gosh
oh I like news over head
firstly it looks real big sword
it means business and I'm always bad at
trying to wake up with the roll you get
the timing for it's weird for me getting
better it like actually remembering it
and get out of combos it's so hard to
remember it when I'm like getting really
scared that they're getting close
Daniel says I'm terrible at the game how
do you remember all the combos for all
the fighters showing even those
tutorials and remembering moves and
timings it's it's kind of just like even
for me right now
after I've played 50 hours I only know
like maybe like two or three strings for
Johnny Cage he's like my favorite guy or
maybe I'll know like two strings for
Kung Lao and I'll do the same combo over
and over again so for me it's just the
brutality use that that tool where you
can actually like tag the moves and just
keep them on your screen while you're
playing that's the easiest way that I've
done it which is a pretty cool addition
to most new fighting games yeah it's
like you just run through arcade mode
like oh I could do this into this and
it's kind of cool that way it was a good
good fight brutality
I don't actually haven't seen that one
for four Codel yet sounds cocky yeah
that was like the first goal I played
against actually can do but I'm not I'm
not
I haven't played Johnny at all I don't
know if you wanna like risk that but I
mean wait did we bring a pad in here so
you can jump into it
this is this is all you this is me
trying to remember and land on my combos
right now it's the goat
I like Baraka a lot but I've never
really like played Baraka like seriously
at all
oops
yes really yeah yeah heck yeah
hey Tim see things yeah I do started out
you know commentary
Marvis Capcom three places like Evo so
it's pretty cool being a GameSpot it's
kind of like a dream dream come true for
real oh it's a pretty good time here
it's pretty great ow
scoops no I can't do those freaking wake
up attacks there's a large rock is the
president of out world brock obama uh
will wake up at saks they don't make any
sense to me i always get like jump why
or a jump exxon accident
there are a lot of people who really
like almost anytime i see anyone talking
about playing online all they're saying
is that they see a bunch of Liu Kang's
the god of bicycle kicks that that blood
ball at the end of that combo you do
always catches me off guard and it's
good to see
oh no it was like the most close fight
ever Oh Michel Martin's in the chat
what's up man oh hey how's it going oh
let's see if we can get back in the room
yeah and yes Michael please come to the
city and we'll get some food it'll be
good times where am I going oh yeah I
hate when it disconnects on the really
good mattress so close one round apiece
oh yeah I'm also wearing a Street
Fighter shirt so it's fitting that
you've arrived to perfect dream oh wait
no no let's see if we could join the
other one first
although we didn't have much luck with
that last day yeah there we are
Oh actually worse there we go this is
perfect that's dirty dirty dirty Dan
he's got that Johnny Cage picture I'm so
stoked yeah someone else is gonna play
Johnny Cage oh no it's a dang it's like
so sad I hope I hope I get the run back
on dirty dirty Dan I know sorry is a
deed a deed an okay what do y'all see
character would you like to see in the
games going off of like what I wanted
from the beginning and what was in the
leaked I I really am either excited or
really want ash Williams I'm stoked
about that I feel like what the MK games
it could literally be anybody yeah yeah
that's the fun part about it I want
cosmic Uryu in mortal combat
even though cure you doesn't kill people
I'm terrified right now by the way oh my
god
I don't I don't know he's such a such a
big guy get some of that that range
going oh I don't know if I can anti-air
yeah but fun oh yeah you can throw it
back it's by the way I guess you have
for Mortal Kombat characters I'd like to
definitely see Cyrax insect or show up
because they're basically in the game oh
of course that second hit was a low oh
gosh oh gosh there it is there it is
I like sonic moons thrown out Donkey
Kong get Donkey Kong in combat why not
yeah oh I wasn't biking that's my
to fight y'all on Xbox one uh so most of
us have copies of m'kay on PlayStation
oh he's gonna meet a brunette no but we
do play other games on xbox it kind of
just depends on where we we have our
copies at we need to do what we do
another Halo day yeah everyone moves a
little bit of Halo and we have been kind
of focusing on the PlayStation side of
things for a bit you get the other
combat kids in there get Takeda comes in
oh my gosh I'm scared I'm scared oh no
that's right now this is this is the one
I can't even wake up Earl I'm so bad
oh my god the whiff punished I'm just
I'm Way too invested in this now I can't
not look at him I am so there you go
no door no no the the duck Dodgers are
real good oh your gums I'm sorry but you
guys you good yes yeah oh man it is the
only fatality I know my life has a real
good fight to my heart my heart I only
know very basic stuff like immortal
comma in general since this is my first
MK I've been trying so it's like the
most nerve-wracking thing when we're
right next to each other and I'm like I
don't know what the best course of
action is right now you can ask almost
any of these people who have been
watching us play through all the Mortal
Kombat games I'm not a person to look at
and be worried about Mortal Kombat stuff
with if the chat is some relieved if the
Comets are to be believed I'm very not
great at Mortal Kombat but I like it a
lot yeah I think you're I think you're
doing fine please you're just had that
road space fight dirty dirty Dan the
ping is non-existent though I really
want to play Dan cuz it looks like he
has a sick look that bad Johnny Cage
[Music]
still trying to get the information here
it seems we're we're definitely loading
that ping any minute now we'll hear back
where it's at
one day thank you for the encouragement
filly prince i try not to panic but it's
really tough
welcome back box night sleeping sounds
like you like you didn't fight me i am
lucky because i feel like i know zero
about shao kahn I'm like oh jeez and she
thinks scary this whole design is meant
to be intimidating it's just like really
tall dude with a giant hammer alike
alright Shao Kahn vs Thor and let's go
pretty good at coop although I I did
pretty well with Cabal especially during
the the beta but like I understand how
the game works I'm just not I'm not
Frankie all these these names rotating
oh they're all failing to connect I've
been challenged I'm accepting everything
by the way yeah
there's some weird weird ping stuff
going on oh there we go
hey box night
oh man okay I thought here thing is
doing a deja vu I've just been in this
place before crime I named my cabal
variant deja vu because I could not do
it the hourglass
who's streaming right now we're
streaming right now assuming right here
for you but if you're wondering who's
playing Persia's playing right now
trying my best but I feel like I'm about
to get real cold oh that was an accident
I said it once I'll say it again
frost is one of the cooler characters in
this game oh four beats Shao Kahn hands
down maybe I don't know Shao Kahn's got
a bigger hammer but Thor's is definitely
heavier walk the the unibeam I know I
was scared I dropped it and I was like
oh no I should just block what have I
been playing lately
pretty much Mortal Kombat it's ever
since we got it in the office that I'm
trying to get back into Final Fantasy 14
because I need to get that regalia
before they take it out of the town yeah
not too much but it's good to see you
though Michael oh my gosh the string the
beam is active for entirely too long I
see if I can land my oath at's true - I
didn't think about Thor's axe
that's it's always uppercuts in and
sweeps I didn't wanna do again I was
like you know it's fine I need to land a
fatal blow at least once you can do it I
believe in Final Fantasy 14 is dope
haven't played in a long time couple
expansion that yeah it's uh it's been
wild there's a new one coming out in
like two months or something but yeah
I'm glad they brought back cabal frost
and noob yeah there's there's some
pretty good people in this roster the
fatal blows are interesting Michael they
like have a little bit of armor but it's
not like invincible and frame ones so
like it's still kind of hit a lot of it
no failed to connects also yeah the
point that a lot of the fatal blows look
like fatalities themselves yeah I guess
that's how some more combat goes oh yeah
it was like you shouldn't survive those
it's true you shouldn't survive them at
all okay Rose I'm crossing my fingers
this is our third time attempting to
connect I mean although all the numbers
are looking good this it might be our
net or something - cuz I know where
that's really weird of all the new
characters who do you think should come
back bring back meet mocap meet and
mocap I want there to be like a really
adorable looking character that's like
completely vicious I think that we don't
something to kind of throw you off
completely we've got some some Kung Lao
action oh boy
I'm skirt yeah you know what teleports
gonna happen we're playing on
PlayStation 4 and if you'd like to join
all you gotta do is search the room name
GameSpot all lowercase letters
join on up and we'll get some some
fights on Gigi pong gamers
Wow so what's not the teleport it's
gonna be that divekick and you're the
end of the meter burn because that those
are the two like super satisfying hunger
out they do you guys use fight sex
Persia does I still use a pad because I
I've never been able to bring myself to
actually full use my stick back when I
got it there it is there's that uppercut
no yes
slobber counts yeah now the roams games
are definitely I feel like a little bit
harder on fight sticks you you were
saying like the the first week while you
were you were digging into it that you
having to extend your pinky over do I've
gotten we're used to it though Oh too
much blood in the stream I'm scared I
don't know what this is what just
focusing up so it's all good
Carlos throws good yeah it is I just
like how many times he hits really fast
with a lot of his stuff nailed it it's
character the flop
yeah it was like good connection all the
way up until like last ten seconds and
then slow-motion pool and the premium
currency the premium goods mm-hmm
was a good pun I try crime as best I can
yes am as owner Michael I'm terrified I
don't want to be close to anybody
I'll need to stay away how do you join
we're playing on the PlayStation 4 all
you gotta do is search the room name
GameSpot in all lowercase letters come
on in and throw down about a mini Goro
is collector just a mini being a blue we
just played you gotta give everyone a
chance yeah you got a lot other people
come in otherwise we'll come back and
serve yeah okay I'm hoping we haven't
gotten a chance play your throws but we
failed to connect everything everything
looks like it's so promising - I don't
understand everything look maybe I
should try to challenge Rose or just do
it the other way yeah yeah because I
know Rose sent a friend request earlier
so oh wait hold on let me try this
reverse Oh see if this doesn't happen
mmm crossing our fingers me mm-hmm
fingers rows where you at where are you
at
okay we definitely do strike her to come
back
I miss striker they ship a Deadpool in
the scenes yeah he'd fit in very very
well let's type the petition young
Deadpool for m'kay yeah there we go the
the dream it's happening right I was
like alright now I can body everyone
hold hands the prayer circle Robert
Bobby says they've been waiting for this
their whole life that's pretty serious
why no finishing moves sometimes it's
just quicker to kind of keep it going
one of my best friends ever please J - a
dose - sure ease out
oh boy oh boy some good some good zoning
happening here real real solid stuff
Jade's got that that immunity though to
range attacks she can pop that one move
yeah her little like purple stiff yeah
yeah some of the moves that you would
think are like projectiles in this game
though don't actually classify as
projectiles shoot I wonder if hang on
will play on ps4 Brock up you good
Deadpool skin reminds me of x-men
origins Wolverine x-men origins
Wolverine was a very good game too dang
that was AI was brutal I was practice
that combo I finally landed it Punk
gamer says I'm going to e3 yeah and I'm
excited it'll be a very good gonna be a
fantastic time so guys please if you're
not following me on twitter at print
underscore XO shameless plug yeah
because after all the like updates are
gonna be and then you know i always
tweet and post pictures and all that
good stuff so follow along with us for
the e3 experience there you go that's
that that's that that's the promo
alright stereotype wants to know as the
PC port really that rough it was rough
at first from my understanding it's been
caught up and there's parity now between
console and PC I don't know if the
switch updates out yet but basically
there was a while where combos and
certain attacks wouldn't work the same
way between the two versions it's like a
combo you do on the ps4 version either
wouldn't worker would do completely
different damage on the PC version
interesting but yes I think they've
brought it up to up to date I don't know
play on PC but
scared do I'm scared a scorpion too he's
another one those characters that I have
like a weird complex with scary
he makes me second-guess everything I do
I'm like oh no is the chain coming
oh no it's because if it's not the chain
is to teleport
wow that's rated cool oh there's a low
effort lad that's so sad now I don't
have bad news
plants which right now the switch one
looks pretty good not gonna lie I'm not
not graphically but like it's really
impressive that they managed to get all
of this game on to that so apparently
this game runs off of Unreal Engine 3
which is nuts if that's the case do
brutality know there might be one for
just doing a back grab and holding back
because there's a lot of them that kind
of go for most characters and they're
pretty similar I want to fight you you
could do it we're on the PlayStation 4
all you gotta do is search the room game
spot and join in toss a challenge to us
when we're back out in the lobby in moil
we'll keep keep them even through
no I've dropped it oh I try it I tried
it that's the spin move is just too much
I love how it looks
yeah there you go
just enough damage who makes a better
combatant Wolverine or Deadpool mmm I
mean that celebrates so good on her feel
like Deadpool problem yeah yeah
Wolverine ugh scorpions got some big
feet wrong Street oh you can tell oh
right that's right it's a spin to win
scenario there's there's kind of no way
around it
Oh everytime every wake up the grab dang
it's a good fight either way punk gamer
so Scylla combos sick thanks I practice
really already landed but I don't always
get it yes scorpions cool cuz he has
like long strings that also like have a
mixture of lows and highs in between
like during them so even if they don't
do that much damage like it gives you
like the reset opportunity is there the
knockdown so and then that spinny chain
man that's that spinning chain move yeah
going around though and that's better
than almost every scorpion oh so you
just kind of work your way through it
and eventually it'll all work out it's a
test of my patience because like deep
down the marble player in
just wants to press all dirty day dirty
dance back okay everyone hold hands
again then let's okay so now try to
challenge him and challenge him to dance
okay now see if this works even though
he's gonna body me my win percentage
odds eighteen look that's fine that
means that there's there's still kind of
a chance that you could win that's
that's pretty good we got this dirty Dan
I want to see some Johnny I want to get
green kicks in my face which is what
happens it's true
Johnny Cage way there it is Marco if I
if I knew the brutality I will do it
I'll try it next time so I have to in
the round with it is that why yeah it's
supposed to be the last day so I'll
trade it in the round with the throw and
hold the throw back there already isn't
yes that instant lock on Jonathan Cage I
know he's ready oh he's ready oh my gosh
this whole time it's like every
character comes up like yeah it doesn't
have much to do with what we're doing
right now Scully but I gave days gone a
five because it wasn't great like that's
it's just an opinion though if you don't
agree with that you can go and you can
play the game too
it shouldn't mess with your enjoyment if
someone didn't like a game do your thing
oh yeah oh god Johnny Cage here and
that's what I'm here for
so I was actually kind of worried that
we wouldn't see Johnny Cage oh is that a
counter yes he's got like uh like a mime
in the box like oh the kicks I thought
it was a time I was like it's gotta
check his pager I do is covet god I
couldn't funded it
I like the variation name to the kind of
a big deal score got a subscription for
me thanks
mr. mr. Iraq I guess my counter is not
as fast appreciate it and if you guys do
like what you see you should definitely
subscribe to the channel we stream every
Johnny Cage oh wait hold on what are we
gonna get the mercy Skylar oh I was kind
of hoping he was gonna go for the
brutality with the oh yeah so there's a
brutality or nothing with the mic - but
with the you can do one with the parry
and it'll actually he'll actually like
pretend like he knocks you down and then
they catch you with a door that isn't
it's real good Skylar like that yeah
it's a good it is good
thank you dirty Dan we finally got a
match with you
heck yeah we're like we gotta see this
Johnny Johnny's gotta happen
John's gonna happen at some point
eventually I'll learn how to break
throws that's the next that's the next
step in the m'kay vortex I feel like I
have understand sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't
I get the concept but then when the
match sounds I'm wise like dang it
alright is this is this the arachnoid
that just said they subscribed or is it
different right oh yeah oh I didn't get
to connect sad face
you know speedy boy I want no more
scorpion action don't do it
it was bound to happen it's okay you
gotta gotta learn from these these
matches they do I do gotta say every
time I lose a match in Mortal Kombat I
feel like I am learning something which
is always a good time I think most of it
it's kind of like Tekken it kind of
reminds me a second you know you got to
learn what all the characters have and
like their options
so the first like few times you play
against a character of course gonna be
rough you're gonna be getting hit by
everything's you never seen it before
especially when you have like a string
not like end in the lower and in a high
you won't know if it's the first time
what it could be a Oh some people have
the throwing ones like the teleport
after a frozen we should we should
challenge our arachnoid she's like when
we a disconnected we can challenge other
people yes that makes me that makes me
double down I'm thinking you might be an
a setting thing so we got to arachnoid
don't worry yeah yeah girl Rosalie yeah
bring him back yeah so apparently Sheva
might be coming back oh yeah I was just
about to I was like oh she shows up in
the story mode and she was in the leak
list but Goro
unfortunately might not be able to come
back because he's there on his throne
he's he's not looking so hot yeah we got
you next arachnoid we'll do that thing
what platform has the most players I
don't actually have numbers but I feel
like usually with its ps4 but apparently
people were seeing some real high
numbers on PC or higher than usual for
fighting games coming I knew still
happening it's doing it yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay so when all else fails you do
that grab that grab is always always a
good option yeah you know I'm not very
smart for constantly going for that a
second time knowing dang well so how did
Goro die he looked like he was just kind
of chillin in his chair some it may be
old age maybe he just got bored it's
kind of sat there for a bit
through the fatal blow oh man oh dang go
what the beanies you cold my hair's bad
so I wear beanie all the time and it is
cold it's San Francisco's like fall all
year round
yeah that's like if you're ever
wondering what the weather's like there
that's that's pretty much it but yeah
wear the beanie squats a day there's
like four of us in the office wearing
beanies today it was like 50 degrees and
I woke up yeah it was pretty cold on the
real
jiejie is let's go find us arachnoid
yeah yeah yeah oh now you Salva vertical
oratory lesson time - oh wait hold up
there we go
let's go arachnoid connecting it'll rake
it just yeah it's it's sorting through
things we gotta send the positive vibes
oh yeah any minute now
who else would be good and m'kay oh it's
raining my imagination and run a little
wild now I feel bad because I saw the
leak and I can't not think about the
leak so I'm sick it's it's all these
people it did a good job of picking up
all the people that I feel like should
kind of be in there but yeah I'm trying
to think he was like really gory that
would just fit I kinda just want
NetherRealm
to make like the monster fighting game
that they want to make was it more calm
at 10 had had predator it had Jason it
had a like an alien in it but just make
like out like a monster fighting game
like a movie monster fighting game I've
always wanted to make my own fighting
game but I think I just have an
overactive imagination and it would be
the most ridiculous and not like
nonsensical fighting game in the whole
world it would definitely be a vs.
fighter 100% movie maybe we just reach
allenge yeah again resend it oh wait
what happened
so hello uh did we get taken away ah
there we go it works yeah for sure
just like we planned it how it happened
it happened looks like he's had a soul
sucked out maybe that's what happened
maybe uh Shang soon got him yeah you're
like a Dracula versus Frankenstein's
monster going like give me all the
Creature from the Black Lagoon put them
in there The Mummy from The Mummy I'm
into it oh I knew is coming again what
am i doing I haven't seen that that noob
outfit yet and you got that sweet sweet
edgy boy a variant name I love it what
about Lola bunny in combat 11 hey you
know why not oops see that's what I'm
excited for rust that Ash was actually
in the leak that's kind of like my dream
mortal kombat character that teleport
man it's like I know what's coming and I
still do something anyways I also use
how much longer we guys streaming about
a half an hour we'll be we'll be taking
some more matches and then want it to
get out of here yeah I'm so bad
[Music]
he's gonna wake up with that swung roll
force which release date I'm not sure
you know what's on the way though oh I'm
trying to jump out of it again I out of
the years like I punished him three
times in a row I don't think I was gonna
change anything
overhead oh no fair ball again those
intense yeah that's the tough thing
about fighting games especially against
like probably people who've never really
played in like a tournament setting it's
hard to like train people online to like
not do stuff like your fighters film
like 5 times in a row
very keep on punishing are good keep
doing it though wow wow that sound every
time so it's like a unique sound just
for that fatality and I just MK an ASMR
Oh on another level see guilty gear I
love guilty gear
I like watching guilty here I never
actually like really played it but
watching it's really fun it's also
probably one of the more most like
beautiful looking fighting games I think
that just I like that art style that's
like so I like schoolgirls see that some
people don't like guys all the
schoolgirls but I'm like I love how can
you know love it it's so good looking it
is like all hand-drawn yeah yeah
I thought was scraping I was like no hey
no worries arachnoid we're happy that we
were able to get that that matching
therefore yeah yeah that's the the
loophole we got a lake if we can't
connect the missionary we got to come
back and connect ourselves the bone
temple thing why skyla getting beat up
in the loading screen I'm gonna leave
that I can't believe this his laugh is
Jesus too much
should we get a game in we're on ps4
join up in the lobby and we can we can
throw down oh you know the armor is so
it's very apparent it exists we all just
have to adapt I don't have to worry
about that while I'm waiting for someone
to throw someone into that the blood
plant or whatever it is
oh my god oh my god
those real close though it was close oh
man I hear they can't jump over stuff
she fears I'd still think you guys
understand like what a review is
supposed to be how you feeling give your
personal opinion high field out it well
what might be a game for one person it
might not be a game for another person
you can still play days gone and have a
good time I can get the throws that I
want every oh man I just looked away for
a second
Shao Kahn went in I wonder why the game
does that like a lot of the times when I
try to give like a throw
I'll just get like a button instead huh
and then it's always like the second
time I go for it comes out but it's
always that first time I try to go
through thrown out tality oh why is my
head down there it's supposed to be on
the top Shao Kahn's found a way to move
it around so it's a wild time GG how do
you tag specific character moves during
a match I see the option but it doesn't
say what button to press so you press
triangle or Y on on xbox and it will
actually put a star next to it and then
when you back out it'll have the
whatever you've tagged like right there
on the thing right underneath your
health bar yeah it's like on the move
list though you gotta take it while
you're looking at that okay I'm gonna
research its Uno's turn he's already
tried to connect with us at least like
three or four times yeah right everyone
just wants to that wants to get in and
do that fight he wants to abiding me
with a scorpion so let's let him do it
here's a press X yes yes I do you
realize that is the way to accept the
match yeah yeah however the connection
has difference has different answers
I believe in you Internet challenge
declines all right we tried we tried I
see a lot of people in here and always
playing each other you guys can
challenge each other to do fights
amongst there you go
do we ever actually fight babyface I
don't know if we did I know we kept
trying to connect aha there we go it
works maybe depending on character oh no
definitely first time yeah I don't think
we've seen any Baraka's a day good it'll
be fine about to make me an hors
d'oeuvre if we posted a review of this
game yet so we have our a written
portion of this review up and we're
going to have our video discussion
either later today or during the weekend
it was a bit of a that you're
undertaking because it was a it's our
first international review conversation
so get ready for that but if you want to
read it it's there but yeah ow
Dominic wants to know who's the main
go-to character for for me it's John
Cage and for you you're very into
Scarlett airbend
from all the way over there no thanks
for pulling me close with the fatal blow
distance everything's good now I gonna
live no oh chip is bad in this game
how come MK 11 has only two fatalities
for chairing px had three or four they
did end up putting a few in later on his
DLC didn't they okay I'd like the
classic pack four fatalities where
everyone got like an old throwback one
and maybe something else but yeah each
character only us two they've got a ton
of brutalities though
no show Connor Kovac on a more of a Shao
Kahn kind of guy can't beat the the
classic Hodel is pretty cool too but
shall for sure oh my god her but she
didn't mean to decline your your match
if you sent one so it is kind of a thing
trying to make sure we get as many
people as we can but you try to get the
throw back again it's just sparking it's
so hard to stop like wake up button it's
so it's so good it was a good match oh
god that fatality is a thing I love that
this was the one that they decided to
like show off the game with yeah he was
even care just the lifeless look on his
eyes like I was like my fifth one I've
had today that's whatever bad @ MK 11
and hello hello Ted it's not for like a
week yeah get it going
what room are we in we're on ps4 and all
you have to do is search GameSpot it's
all lowercase letters come on in we've
actually managed to hold down this same
room the whole stream yeah even when we
got kicked out we're able to come back
in failed to connect No
Andrew what's up how's it going pedido
what's your favorite MK game mine is
Shallon most Shaolin monks is really rad
we wanted to maybe do like a playthrough
of it after we we went through all the
MK games we're like this is the thing we
should probably do it's been a long time
since I've played it and it was really
fun but I think it's it's a toss-up
between 11 and 9 for me for my favourite
MK games okay I love the older ones
I just wasn't super big into them
because it was also kinda at that point
where like I had to sneak that I was
playing them hey mom I need to go on the
internet and look up like what a no
fatality might be for my character this
game is rated M for Mature that was
before my parents were like oh it's fine
their video games you're smart enough to
tell it apart to declines we didn't
we've accepted everything that's popped
up it's not that we're declining it's
the connections failing English yeah it
it's probably the connection or maybe we
just didn't get to yours and time we got
to another one before that but we
promise we're not declining anyone's
matches usually if it fails connect like
once or twice cool out
but uh what's your what's your your name
Daniel will maybe we can try to like
challenge you if we had trouble
connecting Ziya well I understand
because it's also kind of frustrating to
try to like beat twenty other people to
a challenge we want to make sure we try
to fight as many people as we can
so let's note your name is and we'll see
if we can find you
there's the fatality one day I'll then
the other one and it's still pretty
brutal though her other one is a it's
more of like it just makes you feel kind
of uncomfortable well that's two new
byes he's now completely blind can't
believe is Robert Danny D 25 is lower
let's try he will find you Danny yeah my
bad we're trying our best with the
connection yeah yeah I think I can link
off the air to air yeah I kind of saw
that I did it by accident in the last
round I was like oh I did not know I
could do that oh wait hold on hold on
smoke dude Alex I'll challenge you in a
second we gotta give Danny a chance all
right Danny
then after Danny we can hit up quest
city though yeah Vegeta would you do
also tried to connect with this dead
Danny vegeto connecting feel it it's
happening yeah I just have to be patient
and hope for the best
it's kind of like a weird thing to cuz
sometimes when we back out it would just
all of a sudden take us in yeah that's
true two noobs like I can't believe
you've done this won't take long to kill
me hey it's fine
so that's the other big thing about
community Fridays is we don't want to
like tell people that are too
too bad like they can't it's it's just
about kind of hanging out and playing
games and being like man Mortal Kombat
sure is rad about that time scarlet poke
that I have a lot of that guy was weird
yeah guys you guys have been watching me
and get to stray all day alright it's
fine it's fine as much as that you know
that pride inside is like no learning
process yeah we're all we're all doing
it for fun okay let me try to refresh
this maybe it'll work out they get laid
last time
Caitlyn we're playing on the PlayStation
for home entertainment console okay if
this can't connect connecting come on
internet you can do it any minute now
it's just gonna it's going to take off
take it right in that character select I
mean he got matches in so we know that
it is possible it's against we just
can't connect we're trying daddy was
sorry does the kind of school well let
it sit for like maybe like 10 or 15 more
seconds yeah see what happens then we'll
move on yeah sorry sorry if we can't
connect guess I guess you don't know
well come we'll come back and we'll try
again
alright vegeto let's see if we can
connect to you you did try to match up
with those few times in it and it didn't
connect still see how it goes
we're trying we're trying our best we've
got it we've got to send someone else
quarters in the the payphone outside the
CBS office so we can you can get our
internet refreshed
oh he might not be there because he
hasn't even accepted the challenge
declined all right back to the regular
scheduled program accepting to connect
that wasn't me I hit accept y'all I burn
up terrorizing I know they've been
sticking around for a bit
okay I'm gonna find ter I am declining
so we can find Tara rising he's in the
chat he wants to play with us so Jose
Vegeta if it connects try our best
veggie failure to me it wasn't me swear
I swear okay Tara I don't see Tara
raising any let me see don't go up no
it's very possible that they might not
be in here yeah it's alphabetical
oh wait I see him I see him oh there we
go I see him he's right here okay all
right sorry you guys sorry to everyone I
decided to climb we want to give Tara
raising an opportunity he's been in the
chat for a bit so yeah we're both on a
wired connection this this feels good
connecting we're doing it it's happening
so happy Friday violently you guys end
of the week for anyone who's looking
forward to it honestly since working
here I'm like man it's Friday all right
yeah the time just flies back speaking
of time flying by
we're almost in the last 10 minutes of
the stream too which is wild I feel like
we've spent a lot of it trying to
connect every there's still some really
good mattress yeah we did play some good
matches guys you guys are pretty good
you guys are leveling up they bring the
heat I got smacked by so many noob
saibot teleports today do you guys like
the game yeah Spencer I like it I'm a
very good time with it is my four
like m'kay I've actually tried to play
and it's pretty cool it's definitely
takes some getting used to but it's
pretty fun yeah there's just a lot of
stuff in this game like all the
mechanics and gauges and meters and
escapes and wakeup moves and and then
all the characters I'm like my brain and
none of the mechanics are air dashes
where are you guys yeah I'm gonna have
to back out yeah all right we're just
gonna try to accept people until all
right I'm just gonna accept all in
connection works is this IGN no you took
took a wrong turn
see it's we connected we'll try it again
afterwards just can't spend too much
time waiting for it to connect
especially we got our last 10 minutes II
guess yeah it's okay we'll try again
we'll take it I like that Cassie skin
looks just like my friend Romanova well
I think that I think there's Sonya
player look very similar psyche
yeah you got young Sonya and you got
older Cassie and yeah yeah no that's a
very good ow
j.crew knees out but yeah tomorrow's the
4th may the fourth your get ready for it
has a new update that awards the five
hundred coins been released yet I know
it's out on ps4 for a while I think it
hit Xbox and PC not sure if it's on
switch yet though but that should all
all be in for you how long show we've
got about ten more got some good bet so
good Sonya also heard that Sonya is just
very good in this game too
so it's a very good very good Sonia play
ooh
fast project that I'm not the only one
wants to make their own character in an
MK game I hope not
so they try that with I'm gonna mess
this up again cuz they keep getting it
mixed up with the movie mortal kombat
armageddon i think is the the last one
of the three ah I always get benefit she
could actually make your own character
in that one but yeah
making your own comic characters pretty
cool why is wake up super so good cuz
it's got armor it's it's a free game
it's I think they were like we want to
make sure people can do this whenever
they wants thinking it yeah yeah what
are your thoughts on frost as a whole I
never really played frost very much so
I've never been really like frost
earlier oh well yeah she's she's cool I
like what they've done with her she
seems fun she's not my kind of character
but oh god a brutality I feel like if
they're gonna put mercy as in here they
should give the person more life back
because you just die in one combo
anyways yeah dang dang my head is
dislocated from some very good Sonya
play though yeah I actually really liked
a lot of her strings cuz it like hits
you out of the air I was like full peak
neutral jump and her normal button still
hit me out there it was pretty good yeah
red is Armageddon who is the the movie
is I don't even remember the movie title
is anymore because I've tried so hard to
block out reinforce I don't want to say
it but yeah alright Nightwing news or
Nightwing new 52 alright I have accepted
it I like it especially fella connect
with me I swear except so edgy pop up a
little bit earlier
these fails I believe okay
accepting match someone's taking a
little yeah so we're not have time for
like maybe two more matches depending on
how the the connection stuff goes but
yeah like hey he was hovering over noob
or scurvy a man who's a violent
Armageddon in annihilation - two words
that kind of similar feelings to them
yeah our week game spot where two people
who work at GameSpot there we are
representatives yeah we're we're two
people of a large group a bunch of
different people doing a bunch of
different things but right now we're the
two people hanging out playing Mortal
Kombat from GameSpot with you guys
community Friday's chillin doing it
hanging out wait till Goro gets in the
game girls in the game but he's dead
he's in the background of one of the
stages she was alive though that might
be the closest we get unless we're
talking about or like majima Goro from
Yakuza
[Music]
oh wow I felt like that was a teleport
waiting to happen you just missed it
it's coming I feel it oh yeah I'm cavers
DC was the last oh yeah there was I feel
like it was less 3d but it was
definitely the last 3d one you're you
you are a hundred percent correct well
thank you for for hanging out Spencer
Briggs it's it's one thing that we can
sit here and do this but to actually
have you guys come out and show up and
want to play is really a really big part
of it so we really appreciate you guys
doing you I definitely agree that is a
it is a travesty that reptile isn't in
this game that's the one thing that kind
of throws me off character wise Anakin
Skywalker and MK 11 down with that
remember back in the day is Soul Calibur
how Yoda yeah yeah we had star killer
and in Darth Vader - and there's there's
that masters of teras kasi the the
fighting game from the PlayStation that
was not a great game but that Star Wars
characters in it I feel like a
lightsaber in this we would do some
justice oh yeah definitely get kylo Ren
and get the new people kind of expect
the newer um like Star Wars characters
to probably be in it yeah I'm down with
it Wagner Moura says I complain on my
nose disconnected that might be why they
don't work sweet eggs yeah I'm not sure
which person anywhere though your handle
waiting to connect there we go Maji
mokoro and cosmic curio and MK 11 sign
me up
here you asked to get put into some
fighting game and it's gonna end up
being virtual fighter because Sega suck
is the only one that acknowledges okay
night wings about to teach me how to
play some real scarlet I think that's
what's about that mirror match and I
never play played me remember but should
be interesting
I'm here for it
I think you have to press a again oh I
didn't realize I had a had it open
oh man the two the two blood characters
are fighting in the sea of blue it's
just a real a real bloody time reveille
salute only spotting the best games
eight I just like hanging out and
playing games and I'm real stuck that I
somehow I ended up in a place that lets
me do it and I get to hang out with with
people on the internet who are also
stoked about games and that's pretty
great
puts sonic in MK 11 oh yeah I'm down
nothing's off-limits everything is
possible nothing is true everything is
permitted bring back at Co put him in
another fighting game blood for the
blood level O'Brien's Nightwing alright
alright I see you know I didn't break it
it's a close first round it was yeah red
vs. blue version of Mortal Kombat Oh
that'd be pretty interesting actually
please do this more wheat so we have
admittedly not been doing community
Fridays as much as we should we took a
bit of a break for for doing some mortal
kombat catch-up but uh every Friday you
can you can guarantee that we'll be here
trying to play a game with you guys
don't know if we're gonna do mortal
kombat again next week cuz I don't want
to like keep doing this the same thing
it might be maybe we'll do halo next
week
that'd be nice because I keep talking
about it and I want to show the people
over on Xbox at me we still do care
about you guys it's we're not we're not
ps4 only lose you know that are we gonna
do counter-strike 1.6 and that was gonna
be a really weird
situation to Ronald McDonald in them and
que llevan put the Hamburglar and
oh I'm down with that
not even something the showed up in your
sub box that's the power of GameSpot
baby somehow we've hacked it out but I'm
glad that you still showed up even
though you haven't subs and I hope that
this is a thing that you're kind of down
with and maybe you'll consider subbing
won't Leatherface them que llevan
they've already got everything laid out
for him bring him back
oh shoot yeah is is roosterteeth like a
part of Warner I'm not sure about that
I've stopped paying attention a long
time ago Xbox finally broke off
I'm doing a reach registry dang hekia
you do the mercy are you gonna I don't
know how to do it I'm gonna do it
hey you know that's kind of like a mercy
but little bit quicker honestly if I did
them Rosie I probably would've lost I've
know you were gonna lie oh maybe we
could do a rage thing we wouldn't be
able to play rage with you guys but I
mean we like hanging out community
Friday is more of a spiritual thing just
play some Tetris yeah yeah perfectly
timed a very good match to end it on
yeah a mirror the first mirror I'm gonna
switch to order the camera we can close
it out yeah
and you thanks for playing you guys like
you guys have my heart racing that'll
hold like hour and a half yeah there's
some very very good matches I had a good
time watching and hanging out with you
guys in the in the chat while Persia
when definitely beat some people down I
try my best but you guys are strong heck
yeah guys were out for blood but it was
a good time not sure we're gonna do next
week but stay tuned I'm sure we'll be
able to talk about it it's some point
next week stream every single weekday at
11 a.m. Pacific keep it here don't be a
fool stay in school play danganronpa
playoff as a have a good weekend yeah a
great weekend and we'll see you guys
yeah goodbye everybody
I want to find this outro button
[Music]